today I want to talk about doing
something nice for someone else so we
see that a google hangout YouTube chat
with Stephen Kelly who's the CEO of sage
and one of my loyal YouTube viewers love
you guys Roger Bray wrote in the say
that he wasn't going to be able to
attend the live session because he was
doing a chemo session because he has
cancer and he was really sad and he
wanted to then watch the replay and he
said he would watch it afterwards and I
just forwarded that message to steve and
just to let him know that hey there's
this guy who wanted to attend but it
couldn't and Steven did something that
was super nice he created a video to
just send his support out to Roger and I
want to play that for you guys hi
Stephen Kelly ah fantastic day today
Evan google hangout the big message most
important road sure Bray entrepreneur
you know fantastic and I asked go out to
Roger I know you missed the session down
google hangout because you had a really
important part ii on your chemotherapy
that's always most of all we're thinking
of it hope everything goes well with the
chemo of heavily goes well for treatment
and kind of we're with you and evan will
send a message to I just wanted you to
have a personal message to the judge
just jumped off the fly wheel of
entrepreneurs love what you're doing and
enjoy the conversation get in touch with
everyone RI and we're definitely
thinking of you so good luck with all
the tree
why this was super impressive for me was
Stephen thought it was gonna be a
private video i put this up as public
domain for you guys to see because she
was a busy guy right he's the CEO of
sage he's got a multibillion-dollar
company to run he's got over 10,000
employees and here he is at the airport
run in between countries taking a minute
to make a quick video for someone who he
doesn't even know just to wish them
while and I think it speaks to the kind
of guy that Stephen Kelly is but also is
a great reminder that you know you guys
should take time out of your day on a
regular basis to do nice things for
people just be a nice person and spread
a little bit of good Carm out in the
world and so it's hoping that today we
could do two things 1 i'd love to extend
my wishes to Roger as well and I hope
believe nation you guys will leave a
comment below wishing Roger on he's been
I think seven years now going through
this and he's fighting the chemo and
it's fighting the cancer and Roger you
know we're with you when and hope you
recover and and have a you know full
recovery in great health and I want you
guys leave a comment to support him and
2 i'd also love to know what else you
going to do today to make someone's day
just to be nice do something nice to
make someone's day better leave it in
the comments below thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and i'll
see you soon